ja und für uns auf mallorca ist hier
biermann twitter stehst jetzt vor dem
deutschen eck ich das richtig sehe das
ist eine der beliebtesten kneipen
eigentlich bei deutschen urlaubern
trotzdem will ich als allererstes fragen
wie gehen eigentlich die mayo china
jetzt mit diesen schließungen um wenn
relativ offensichtlicher die urlauber
schultern haben ja die spanischen banken
damit er nicht sprechen konnte
zeugen größtenteils verständnis für die
schließungen auch die jetzt auch gerade
eine frage denn sie erinnern sich gut
daran dass noch bis vor wenigen monaten
bis vor zwei monaten in spanien er
wirklich ein extremer locker und anders
als in deutschland beherrschte und dass
die korona krankenhäuser überfüllt waren
und deswegen hat es für ungut bei den
spaniern gesorgt diese bilder dass
bayern im deutschen zu sehen nach dem
motto zuhause benehmen sie sich befolgen
womöglich die regeln und hier in spanien
lassen sie die sau raus und gefährden
die spanier gleichzeitig ist halt die
wirtschaftliche lage extrem angespannt
egal mit wem man spricht sei es der halo
helmut sonnenbrillen verkäufer aus dem
senegal sei es ein gastronom sei es ein
taxifahrer oder auch prostituierte alle
berichten von einem umsatzeinbruch von
circa 80 prozent und das ist wirklich
dramatisch da die mallorquina die hier
leben also die auf der insel leben das
geld was sie im winter brauchen im
sommer sammeln
deswegen geht man davon aus dass es im
winter eine schwierige lage wird die
meisten haben ja keine mietwohnung
sondern kaufen und kann dann womöglich
ihre hypotheken nicht mehr bedienen und
bei den deutschen auswanderern ist es so
dass grob gesagt ist zwei gruppen gibt
es gibt welche die in der die kids ihren
sich mit der situation der spanier
erinnert sich auch an die schwierige
lage auf dem festland sie sagen diese
regeln sind richtig dann gibt es eine
andere gruppe die einen regelrechten
hass jetzt auf die medien entwickelt
haben auch auf die deutschen medien die
sagen das sei alles eine lüge und
ergeben den medien die schuld daran dass
die leben geschlossen haben und rufen
teils zur hetzjagd auf journalisten auf
diese leute sind dann auch größtenteils
im tourismus tätig und
man kann dann natürlich auch
nachvollziehen die dass sie einen in
einer extrem schwierigen
wirtschaftlichen lage sind wie man jetzt
hier sieht an der bierstraße es ist
wirklich alles leer
hier werden normalerweise hektoliter
bier getrunken und es werden euros in
die insel kasse gespürt dass fehlt jetzt
alles ja einige touristen sagten auch
das ist das erste mal dass mallorca so
leer sei so entspannt wie konnten dem
auch was positives abgewinnen aber ja